jérôme rothen est derrière veolia
suspendu d'antenne choqué pas choquer on
va revoir la vidéo du débat voilà répond
bien montrer à nos téléspectateurs ce
qui a fait qu'ils ont été suspendu
d'antenne par rmc regarder mais je
sentais venir les nouveaux résidents
dans les sections c'est très con et
aries intersidéral et je suis déçu de la
deuxième division c'est à dire
franchement dès qu'il peut avoir plus
qu'il venait freely 2007 a réuni à c'est
qu'on peut faire un débat parallèle mais
ce qu'on aime à parler ses histoires et
ses dix ans rien n'est pas pareil
attends quand tu t'appelles neymar il y
ait un minimum de qualité voilà quand
même tâche était que huit y fait
normalement c'est celle championne si au
moins ça a passé 8e faire venir prendre
l'avion le csa a débarqué à cerner en
plus l arrivée tu te retrouves dans la
merde jouent les barrages face à lorient
on va faire quelque chose alors on vous
a montré la vidéo
donc aujourd'hui je vous le dis ils ont
été suspendu d'antenne
je vous le dis très vite le présentateur
nicolas villa lui avoua vu que ça allait
faire un bad buzz ou live est la même
dans la vidéo et je vous le dis elle a
été vue 715 750 mille fois la vidéo et
les missions du 6 juin à d'ailleurs été
retirée du replay du site rmc rmc a
décidé lundi après-midi d'annuler avec
effet immédiat
toute participation à l'after foot selon
le parisien ils seront tous les deux
reçu par la direction milieu de semaine
afin d'évoquer leur sort voilà je vous
dis ils ont également repris les mots
qu'aurait tenus le directeur général de
rennes ce terrain des sports nous
condamnons fortement les propos tenus à
l'antenne par jérôme rothen et daniel
riolo ils sont inacceptables
la société des journalistes de rmc s'est
désolidarisé des propos tenus oui
bonsoir par avaya qui rigole merci alors
la société des journalistes
je crois que c'est doc gynéco voilà non
est ce qui se passe ah oui j'ai perdu
mon adacore très bien alors la société
des journalistes de rmc s'est
désolidarisé des propos tenus à
l'antenne et condamne fermement les
propos sexistes et injurieux et ce mardi
le csa fera les comptes du nombre de
plaintes reçues ces derniers jours
alors pour cette séquence on vous pose
la question est ce que vous êtes choqués
ou pas choquer
qu'il soit suspendu d'antenne matthieu
delormeau vous n'êtes pas choquer pour
vous il devait être suspendu dès ce
dimanche en revanche est évidemment très
choquée par les propos particulièrement
et c'est pas parce que tu es là par ceux
de jérôme rothen
voilà je vous dis franchement quand il
dit quand on s'appelle neymar on a
besoin d'un minimum de qualité
c'est horrible pour les femmes et ça
laisse même entendre en plus que
éventuellement le viol ça dépend
peut-être de la qualité de l'eau c'est
la vie est belle c'est ouzou n'est pas
belle se comprend si la fille est moche
c'est ce qu'on peut comprendre mais
c'est ce qu'on peut comprendre quand on
le voit quand on s'appelle les marques
faut un minimum de qualité pour faire
venir une fille est couché avec oui là
j'ai été très choqué
choqué par ça et puis choqué aussi un
petit peu après derrière aussi femme ça
sonne au dessus j'avais bombe en tout
cas oui choqué par ça effectivement et
je trouve que c'est normal qu'on ait
suspendu et je sais que c'est pas
politiquement correct alors suivez-moi m
choqué par la suspension vous trouvez
qu'il n'aurait pas dû être juste pour
lui franchement j'ai entendu delrieu
l'eau souvent m'énerve je vais pas vous
mentir souvent il tient des propos
rappellent que c'est le compagnon de m
je suis là personnellement c'est vrai
que je suis fan de lui mais en fait dans
le coup dans le personnage c'est ce
qu'on adore détester on et j'aime
l'écouter m'énerver auprès de lui parce
que c'est un journaliste mais c'est
aussi un polémiste cette blague qu'il a
fait cette remarque peu importe
ok c'est un truc de beauf je suis
d'accord peut-être que daniel riolo et
un bof je n'en sais rien je ne connais
pas dans la vie de tous les jours mais
on arrivait at qu'il soit viré je trouve
ça lamentable et la terreur que marlène
schiappa rire et mais dans le paf c'est
assez lamentable alors sans avoir la
vidéo de marlène schiappa bal avec qui
on s'entend bien on va pas se mentir sur
leur âge beaucoup et moi je le prends
alors c'est son boulot non pas son
boulot c'est son boulot
oui c'est un article de loi du 4 août
2014 qui demande au csa
justement extrêmement attentifs aux
propos sexistes selon les médias le
voilà cette fois je cet article est
écrit on avait mis des millions de
non je peux parler c'est la loi c'est à
dire le gouvernement qui demande au csa
c'est pour te dire que justement ça
vient des politiques alors ces réactions
à mein chappard gardel est venu à lui
revenu sur les propos de daniel riolo et
jérôme rothen donc vous vous nous dites
que le csa demande au gouvernement
d'agir dans ces cas là non c'est le vent
qui demandait sa d'agir et bien c'est sa
décision est extrêmement attentif là
dessus même si elles n'étaient pas
intervenues le csa ce serait si c'est ça
je pense qu'avec les regarde c'est très
classique ont interpellé les choquer ce
n'est pas la c1 et marron portel
néanmoins il contribue à la culture du
jeune qui est incomplète et qui relève
de tout ce qui tend à minimiser excusé
plaisanté voir promouvoir une forme de
culture du jeune et donc de les arrêter
au tour des agressions sexuelles du
harcèlement sexuels et des viols que
vivent les femmes et certains hommes
c'est notamment justement ce type de
propos c'est à dire ceux qui constituent
ce qui pouvait pas vous à se moquer des
femmes qui accusent également débat oui
on reste sur le débat c'est est ce que
vous êtes choqués vous je me suis
stressé je suis très je suis très étonné
que christine kelly soient choqués par
un suspendu d'antenne et je trouve que
c'est c'est bien vous soyez honnêtes la
thur alors je vais vous dire je suis
choqué par les propos aient choqué par
la suspension
il n'y a pas longtemps un journaliste de
moov a eu des propos sexistes il a été
suspendu
beauxis si vous voulez c'est un peu à la
mode en ce moment effectivement de
suspendre je trouve qu'une fois qu'il se
soit excusé
une fois que de toutes les façons le
sait ça fera son étude
de toutes les façons ça ne vous ça ne
sert à rien de les suspendre parce que
ça sera contre productif pour la cause
des femmes après pour moi on va un petit
peu trop loin
cela dit je trouve que je faut prendre
ça aussi dans un contexte de groupes de
chaînes
l'autre jour rmc a été mise en demeure
par le csa pas avoir diffusé une finale
des champions flémalle ligue des
champions et attention voilà je pense
pression à leurs aînés graduelle et le
rmc bfm est dans l'oeil du cyclone donc
à mon avis on dit là c'est mon info vite
pas il faut interagir parce qu'ici on va
s'en prendre plein la gueule
vous n'êtes pas que ce match pourrait
choquer par la suspension donc dans ce
sens que c'est seulement une suspension
et j'espère qu'ils ne seront pas le
virer schulz a nommé les pavés une
suspension
ça permet aussi de prendre un peu de
temps de faire réfléchir les gens et de
faire avancer un peu les idées et les
mentalités donc ça je trouve ça plutôt
pas mal en revanche
ce qui est incroyable c'est que c'est
plutôt une faute professionnelle qu'ils
ont fui ce genre d'une discussion il
aurait eu dans un dîner à table avec des
copines c'est à tout le moins les filets
de retraités macho de ringard de pauvres
les hommes se seraient descendus on
aurait bu un coup ça serait passé
personne n'aurait rien dit sur la c3
autour d'une table et là du coup il
balança comme ça sans qu'il ait aucun
contradicteur ni rien là devant vous
évidemment c'est pas assez alors pour
moi ce que je remarque c'est que il ya
cinq filles autour de autour de la table
et quatre sur cinq ne sont pas choqués
il ya qu'isabelle qui n'est pas choqué
de quais qui comprend la suspension les
autres sont choqués par suspension
brille pas de mine mais oui parce que
jérôme rothen et daniel riolo ce qu'ils
ont dit c'est ce qu'ils ont dit c'est
totalement con c'est totalement bête
c'est stupide tout ce que vous voulez
c'est que si ce boss
choisissez les qualificatifs hadji les
adjectifs que vous souhaitez en revanche
ils ont une réaction immédiate web
ils n'ont pas attendu quand ils se sont
rendus compte de leur bêtise sans fil
ont immédiatement réagi des colorado
devant des noms non pardonne-moi daniel
riolo a tweeté immédiatement par
ailleurs il a immédiatement appelé
maryland chapa il a eu marlène schiappa
au téléphone ils ont il lui a demandé si
elle était d'accord pour intervenir dans
l'émission qui suivait le dimanche soir
elle est intervenue elle a pu dire le
message est effectivement il a pu faire
à nouveau comme contrition donc quand on
fait contrition deux fois je pense que
c'est c'est dit c'est dire qu'on a pris
l'ampleur et féconde éruption est con on
est con à primelin qu'on a pris
l'ampleur du problème et qu'on attend
donc les contrer si on avait dérapé
qu'on avait des rares à quévy et ignacio
bien sûr d'acompte répétant la conterie
un hâle contrite alors qu'elle y tuer
choqué par la suspension
moi je suis choqué dans un sens ou ok
c'est une conversation de bistrot qu'on
n'aurait pas dû avoir à l'antenne mais à
un moment donné je pense qu'un peu de
naturel fait pas mal même si je suis pas
d'accord avec ce qu'ils ont dit et en
plus de ça la meuf n'est pas c'est
dégueulasse que ça non oui parle d'un
viol qui lient leur peut-être peut-être
des corps et des juges le physique d'une
femme alors oui c'est pas joli c'est
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas disent
passer à l'antenne mais je trouve que
les sanctions sont trop fortes ils ont
fait contrition et
non mais c'est sa taille mais non mais
ce qui est très bien s'en servir à bon
jour non mais j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
gérard gillmann lis pas ce que je veux
moi j'aurais pas ce changement
franchisés suspendu veux pas qu'ils sont
l'avenir et la misère comme exprimant
jamais rêvé vous êtes heu mais ouais
merci mais non c'est très important
d'avoir géraldine maillet mine de rien
et d'avoir l'avis de géraldine giraud
dim vous vous êtes choqué e pas la
suspension d'antenne parce qu'on fait
valérie a tout dit effectivement c'était
totalement ratée des plats salés aurait
parlé avec avec derniers mois j'ai
envoyé un texto pendant l'émission sera
exempt mais c'était pas drôle doux en
fin - d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est
que la vanne est pure maintenant genre
continue rentrer le soir pas de dessert
ici bien sûr toujours des desserts façon
vous savez vous en savez quelque chose
deux heures d'émission en direct tous
les soirs depuis douze ans avec ce côté
effectivement café du commerce n'est pas
toujours évident d'abord je voudrais
dire à mathieu que la la blague
même si elle est pas bonne évidemment et
est très très gênante
elle est totalement décorrélé de
l'histoire du viol les atomes de 10 2 3
fois il recontextualise dans un autre
côté et effectivement c'est comme ça on
qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas que ce soit
sexistes ou que ce soit pas sexiste les
footballeurs sont connus pour quitter
leur femme
les historiques et prend des top models
voilà c'est affreux mais c'est comme ça
bon ensuite aussi jeter nous faire
voulue par laure manadou le jeu de mai
après effectivement mal à trouver que
l'on voit de son épouse et quelques
monstres qui se sont excusés de trois
jours sauf que personne n'en a parlé à
maintenant alors je voulais dire que ça
prend bien que c'est parce qu'elle aura
dessiné mais cela fait dire parce qu'en
fait ça fait un buzz trois jours après
oui voilà c'est ça christine cette
partie donnait forme et donc ils se
savaient que je lisais normalement le
chef et marlène schiappa était
formidable elle est venue c'est que
s'exprimer dans l'after elle a dit que
c'était très bien qu'ils s'excusent que
ça permettait de relancer le débat que
c'était tout à leur honneur qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensez vous géraldine
mallet voilà si voilà si vous ne
connaissiez pas de viron bretonne et
daniel riolo que ce que vous auriez vous
mais moi je pense que c'est pas illégal
de se moquer du physique d'une femme
c'est pas une égale de dirhams amical et
vieilles c'est pas illégal de dirhams
via inkala de la moustache c'est pas
illégal de dire à kelly b2b lit que les
prétextes ou qu'elle n'est pas un prix
nobel
ces pagnes voyez ce que je reviens pas
c'est sûr que ce soit en fait si je
perds vite qu'on le dit si tous les
soirs m'a fait pas pour autant qu'eux
on se lève de table en ayant l'air
choqué en dix ans mais mon dieu quelle
honte que ce soit beauf que ce soit
grivois que ce soit café du commerce que
ce soit un truc entre coluche et josiane
absolument je lui dis ce n'y a pas de
problème mais de la suspendre de
l'antenne je trouve que c'est beaucoup
et j'aime vraiment ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs je vais vous donner mon
avis as-tu choqué 47% par la suspension
pas choquer 53% voilà c'est après
l'erreur qu'il restera mois ses 55 ans
louis alors phoenix le tableau le
plateau ici là-bas y avait que des
hommes aient vraiment ça que tu es un
gros titre alors c'est un ancien de foot
moi je voudrais dire c'est vrai que je
pense que daniel riolo et jérôme rothen
qui sont très intelligents tous les deux
savent qu'ils y voilà ils ont ils ont
fait une bêtise en parlant comme ça
alors à l'antenne parce que voilà c'est
ça ce n'est si c'est surtout à l'antenne
que ça choque voilà parce que je vous
dis la vérité
alors à tous les temps du des mecs
parler comme ça hors antenne et s'est
massé mal de le faire hors antenne est à
l'antenne mais c'est vrai que
malheureusement voilà c'est sur une
émission qui marche une émission qui est
très écoutée maintenant que ce soit
daniel ou jérôme pour les connaître tous
les deux assez bien je vous jure c'est
les mecs sans doute gentleman
franchement je vous jure que c'est vrai
là ils sont partis on voit là ils ont
fait une connerie quand on peut tous en
faire et il était avec des potes ils
sont et se sont ils ont cru qu'ils
étaient tous les deux voilà un pote en
train de discuter et ils sont partis
dans l'enchaînement de vannes voilà sony
qui bat le plus manier le monde gare de
caudry et c'est vrai que ils ont
regretté tous les deux mais que ce soit
daniel ou jérôme je peux vous dire c'est
vraiment les deux des mecs top
vraiment je le dis je je voilà j'ai dit
daniel amorcions - d'ailleurs on nous en
ouverture des trucs et des jets je vais
dire une connerie je sais ça d'ailleurs
il le dit après c'est vrai que c'est pas
bien ce qu'ils ont fait maintenant on a
confectionné par daniel riolo et jérôme
rothen ils font des émissions en direct
daniel y prend des risques inconsidérés
à l'antenne comme personne n'en
prendront pas fait je le dis franchement
c'est un des seuls mecs qui a vraiment
des iops dans le parc parce que
franchement il y va il donne son avis
sur tout et il n'a jamais peur de donner
son avis c'est normal parfois d'eux
surtout déraper un peu il a dérapé il le
sait lui-même il a vite reconnu il a dit
at il dit annie lavoix là et il s'est
excusé et aujourd'hui voilà je pense que
voilà on est haut on est en droit de
dire voilà on accepte les excuses de
daniel riou loin et jérôme rothen rmc
les a suspendus je pense c'est très bien
aussi
rmc pour marquer le coup 2
suspendre jérôme et daniel pour un
moment et qu'après revers laden mais
leur donner voilà alors dit voilà c'est
plus possible de le faire
une prochaine fois et de les sanctionner
je pense que comme vous l'avez dit si
vous êtes plus voilà vous êtes contents
de la sanction mais il faut voilà il
faut pas non plus renier complètement et
je pense vraiment que ce sont deux mecs
qui ont un très grand talent
quoi qu'il arrive et jérôme et daniel et
se sont baladés mec bien qui se sont
excusés tout de suite voilà moi je vous
dis juge jérôme rothen au téléphone tout
à l'heure qui m'a appelé durant et il
n'était pas bien et m'a dit fois la
série j'ai fait une connerie tu me
connais tu as vu je parle jamais comme
ça je sais pas ce qui nous a pris on
était dans une ambiance à tous les
débats il est vous allez bientôt le
moscato chose oui c'est puissance 1000
milles lundi cela ils le font mais c'est
très c'est pourquoi tout d'un coup on va
décider de sanctionner parce que in
affaire je suis désolé dans le moscato
on sait que c'est grivois on sait que
c'est vrai ça et c'est ça qui n'en fait
c'est là qu'on aime c'est bof
ok mais il mérite pas d'être sanctionné
et c'est bien ce qu'il a dit serena
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]